[Música]
i
desde chicos ya muy chiquito más que
ahora ya quería ser biólogo ecólogo o
tener alguna relación con la naturaleza
y como todo chico me imagino que ustedes
también miraba muchos programas de
televisión y sobre todo documentales con
documentales en donde yo quería hacer
ese científico que se metía en el medio
de la selva y cruzaba los más terribles
escenarios para buscar ese animal único
en el mundo y poder fotografiarlo
estudiarlo o quizás llegar a ver la
floración de una planta que una vez al
año
florecía
si bien
logré llegar a ser biólogo hoy en día
después de varios años de estudio
me recibí como biólogo y trabajo de ello
y también
tránsito la selva misionera estudiando
especies organismos no son los grandes
mamíferos de la selva paranaense o las
majestuosas aves
o las plantas o los insectos muy muy muy
raros que existen que ustedes deben
conocer
sino que me dediqué a estudiar unos
organismos los seres
yo los llamo los discriminados de la
naturaleza
porque estoy seguro que la mayoría no se
los imagina en su mente cuando piensa en
un ambiente selvático en un bosque en un
monte
y también estoy seguro que diariamente
los utilizan ustedes sus padres
y además
estoy también cien seguro que a la
mayoría de ustedes en algún momento un
compuesto derivado de ellos les ha
salvado la vida más de una vez
y a pesar de que cada vez que me
preguntan cuál es mi especialidad en la
biología y yo hago esta introducción a
pesar de que les cuento todo eso cada
vez que les digo que trabajo con hongos
me ponen
esta cara hongos
sí sí trabajo con hongos cuál es el
problema y los vi y hay muchísimos que
pusieron esa cara cuando yo dije que
trabajaba con hongos
y realmente somos muy injustos con los
hongos gracias a estadísticas de nuestra
página web de hongos de argentina
pudimos observar que el 60 por ciento de
las personas que ingresan a la página se
preguntan qué son los hongos simplemente
qué son los hongos
estoy seguro que muchos de ustedes que
están acá no se pregunten qué es una
planta o qué es un perro diariamente
pero si lo hacen y se preguntan qué son
los hongos está bien no lo saben
y fíjense ustedes qué injusto que somos
peor aún que encima que no sabemos lo
que son que nos generan asco disgustos
tendemos a solamente relacionarlos con
su toxicidad o si son comestibles no nos
imaginamos otras características que no
sean simplemente eso
al desconocimiento a la falta de
información le agregamos miedo y claro
es lógico lo que no conocemos tiende a
darnos miedo
incluso en argentina como así también en
otras partes del mundo existe una fobia
a los hongos denominada mico fobia
durante esta charla quiero demostrarles
y quiero mostrarles que los hongos son
mucho más que comestibles o tóxicos o
alucinógenos o ese hongo que tanto nos
molesta es que nos genera pie de atleta
los hongos cumplen un rol importantísimo
lo han cumplido durante la historia de
la humanidad ya un poquito les contaba
desde la fermentación del pan vinos
cervezas e incluso el desarrollo de un
antibiótico de los más importantes como
es la penicilina y que yo hacía
referencia a que estoy seguro que les ha
salvado la vida en algún momento y que
ustedes nunca lo tuvieron en cuenta
pero así también como cumplieron un rol
importantísimo la historia de la
humanidad cumplen un rol aún más
importante en el ecosistema todos los
días de manera silenciosa sin que
ninguno lo piense lo tenga en cuenta y
ese rol es el de descomponer compuestos
orgánicos ramas troncos hojarascas todo
el tiempo ellos están degradando
continuamente y si no lo hicieran en
este momento estaríamos como este
muchacho tapados totalmente de restos de
madera de hojas de residuos urbanos
y si por encima del suelo tienen ese rol
tan importante que es el de degradar
cosas por debajo están teniendo aún un
rol muchísimo más importante que es el
de relacionarse con las plantas se
relacionan íntimamente de una manera
simbiótica en donde ambos se ven
beneficiados
y si nosotros pensamos en ese bosque
como una gran red conectada por el
cuerpo verdadero de los hongos el
micelio que es el que está inserto en
ese suelo inserto en esa madera en esas
hojarasca
en esos insectos que a veces incluso
pueden para citar
si nosotros pensamos en ellos como una
red
y lo tratamos de graficar se asemeja
muchísimo a un mapa de redes de millones
y millones de computadoras a un mapa de
internet en donde cada computadora es un
árbol y los cables de conexión es el
micelio de los hongos y cuando nosotros
de fort estamos sin ninguna
planificación sin ningún conocimiento lo
único que hacemos es destruir y esa red
de manera irreversible
que nos interesa a nosotros los
científicos los biólogos y que está
empezando a interesar en el mundo y a
poner la mirada en los hongos porque nos
interesan tanto y qué es lo que yo les
quiero mostrar a partir de ellos y de
sus características de sus funciones en
el ecosistema podemos utilizarlos en
nuestro beneficio en un beneficio común
no personal no para fundar una empresa y
llenarlos de dinero beneficio para
nuestra región para nuestros amigos para
nuestra familia
algunos de los ejemplos que les puedo
dar es como este el de chido oberá
a partir del concepto de que los hongos
pueden degradar cosas
ella ha capacitado a comunidades de
congo ghana zimbabwe diferentes países
de áfrica en donde lamentablemente los
alimentos todavía escasean y mucho a
partir de la utilización de los residuos
locales sin tener que irse muy lejos y
de los hongos también locales ella puede
darle a esas familias una fuente de
alimento e incluso generadores y un
insumo extra para sus familias
y para el otro lado para que vean
también que los hongos son muy
inclusivos
no muy lejos en rotterdam holanda unos
muchachos unos amigos tomando un café se
dieron cuenta que cada vez que pedían
una tacita de café expresso se generaba
un subproducto un residuo que en grandes
y grandes volúmenes llegaban a ser
tóxicos y se preguntaron por qué no
probar si los hongos comestibles podían
crecer en él y los resultados eran
fueron muy buenos
demasiado buenos al punto de que hoy en
día son un ejemplo de lo que
consideramos una economía circular en
donde a partir de un residuo generamos
un alimento y ese alimento vuelve a
ingresar al mercado alguno de los hongos
que pueden ser utilizados los tenemos
acá en el jardín de su casa si salimos
por un sendero lo podemos encontrar
y esta capacidad que les contaba que
tienen los hongos para degradar cosas no
solamente se limita a compuestos
orgánicos también son capaces de
degradar compuestos inorgánicos y esos
compuestos inorgánicos la mayoría los
generamos nosotros y son tóxicos para el
ambiente
eso que ven en la foto es un suelo
contaminado con hidrocarburos derivado
del petróleo algo que vuelve a los
ecosistemas inertes la vida en esos
suelos parece ser imposible
pero si podemos tratar esos suelos con
hongos con esas bolsas de cultivo que
les mostraba antes como ven en la foto
esos hongos tienen la capacidad de
crecer en ese ambiente ir degradándose
compuesto tóxico neutralizar lo
neutralizar su toxicidad
y no solamente eso
luego de un tiempo incluso ya que la
toxicidad ha bajado se empiezan a
generar hongos no empiezan a producirse
hongos esos hongos que pasa atraen
insectos esos insectos atraen aves esas
aves traen consigo semillas y esas
semillas se dispersan germinan y ese
ecosistema se recupera totalmente a ese
proceso ese ciclo lo consideramos una
remediación y en el caso de utilizar
hongos una micro remediación pero si
hablamos de contaminantes de tóxicos uno
de los peores para mí uno de los que
está en el top five de los peores
contaminantes son los plásticos los
plásticos el telgopor compuestos que
nosotros generamos porque nada nos es
fácil generar los no son útiles no
podemos darle cualquier forma pero
ustedes piensen que están generando que
están utilizando un producto de una vida
útil muy corta funcional a veces
segundos
en algunos casos productos que no duran
años pero la vida tóxica en el ambiente
es de cientos y cientos de años
imagínense ustedes ahora un panorama en
el cual puedan producir un producto
un material que tenga una vida útil
razonable funcional a lo que ustedes
quieran pero que su vida útil posterior
sea de algunos segundos es al revés la
cuenta la vida útil ahora es larga la
que nosotros querramos y posteriormente
durará lo que nosotros determinemos esos
materiales ya existen en esta foto ven
algunos ejemplos y están basados en una
característica de los hongos los hongos
producen un pegamento natural el micelio
este que les comentaba este pegamento
nos permite que podamos mezclar residuos
también locales aserrín paja de trigo
cereales subproductos de la industria
agro forestal por ejemplo y que junto
con éste michelle yo podamos darle la
forma que querramos a los productos que
querramos casi como hornear un pan
producirlos en nuestra casa inclusive y
luego de que los utilizamos ese producto
nos sirve como abono para nuestro jardín
entonces ahora imagínense la situación
para navidad para año nuevo para nuestro
cumpleaños nos regalan un televisor una
computadora y viene repleto de todo ese
telgopor que viene que lo utilizamos
para que el transporte sea seguro ahora
no solamente no nos van a estar
regalando una computadora un televisor
sino también abono para nuestro jardín o
sea tenemos un doble regalo no estos
hongos también los tenemos acá en la
selva paranaense hongos como el género
ganado arma hongos que ya conocíamos por
lo menos los que estudiamos biología
porque hace años y años las comunidades
más antiguas las culturas más antiguas
que vienen utilizando para potenciar el
sistema inmunológico
hablando de eso
hoy en día las que necesitan
de nuestra ayuda son las colonias de
abejas los insectos y en particular las
colonias de abejas porque estamos
pasando por la peor época de mortandad
de colonias de abejas y ustedes saben
perfectamente que sin abejas la vida en
esta tierra no podría ser la misma
como les contaba anteriormente los
extractos de ganoderma los hongos como
ganoderma anteriores potencian el
sistema inmunológico y por qué no probar
con nuestras amigas las abejas
bueno la realidad que se ha probado y
los resultados son realmente
prometedores la mezcla de agua azucarada
con extractos de estos hongos casi como
hacerse un tereré o un mate produce que
el sistema inmunológico de las abejas se
potencie y pueda soportar enfermedades
como el ácaro varroa destructor por
ejemplo que es uno de los peores males
para las colonias de abejas
chicos con esto lo que estoy diciendo es
que
estamos viviendo una época en donde el
exceso de plásticos en los mares por
ejemplo se supone que nos va a llevar a
que en 2050 haya más plástico que peces
en los océanos donde estamos generando
continuamente contaminantes que vamos
tirando a ríos mares arroyos sin ninguna
idea de lo que estamos generando
las ganas el deseo que tenemos de
obtener alimentos continuamente en
grande cantidad fuera de temporada nos
lleva a utilizar justificadamente
pesticidas herbicidas fertilizantes
productos inorgánicos que nos llevó
incluso a que en agosto de este año
hemos consumido 1.7 planetas o sea la
tierra pareciera ser que ya no nos
soporta
yo creo que incorporar hongos al sistema
nos da un poquito de esperanza nos da
realmente esperanza estoy convencido de
que va por ahí el camino o por lo menos
es uno de los caminos también espero que
con esta con esta charla
tengan otra perspectiva de qué son los
hongos tengan otra idea
y lo tomen como un ejemplo
un ejemplo de que hay veces que las
soluciones a problemas complejos pueden
venir de las fuentes más simples e
inesperadas
tarde
[Aplausos]
[Música]